in february2014 comcast agreed to buy
time warner cable for forty five point
two billion dollars in stock the merger
would combine the nation's two largest
cable operators into a massive company
with about thirty million subscribers
more than triple the amount of its
closest cable competitor and for
regulators those numbers could be a
problem with that many customers the
combined company could have unfair
competitive leverage against TV channels
and other businesses offering online
video streaming like Netflix this is why
antitrust attorneys at the US Justice
Department are leaning towards
recommending the Comcast's bid to buy
Time Warner be blocked one of the
Justice Department's concerns is that
such a large company could unfairly
charge internet video providers which
would ultimately hurt consumers the DOJ
is reviewing Comcast's passive thirty
percent stake and streaming service Hulu
lawyers want to know if comcast was to
actively involved when co-investors Fox
and Disney tried to sell Hulu in 2013
Comcast denies having had any role of
decision not to sell the government
rejection would be a blow to Comcast the
merger is a way for it to fend off
competitors have taken hundreds of
thousands of its TV subscribers in the
past decade Netflix for example had
nearly twice as many subscribers as
Comcast at the end of 2014 another
company affected by the merger charter
communications which lost out to Comcast
a year ago in its own bid to buy Time
Warner Cable if the merger falls through
charter could get another shot